una crisis humanitaria inminente la sport
asd europa mille migrantes encuentra
n'atra pas dosé en una tierra de magia y
el área frente pelea entrada bielorrusia e
Polonia si explicas la entrada desde el país.
europea y cuando tiene la intención de marchar
atrás también son estado de dirección para el
sau vuelve a mostrarlo roncando a la entrada
empresas de temperatura para buscarse
en el extranjero grados sureños la masacre de
a medida que se elevan a la prueba de mi dios un
ubicado en el dormitorio forestal informa al
policía hermana argot del cadáver a
papel entre las presiones de corte seremos capaces de
descubrir marca es el cuerpo de un
po ha estado vendiendo la nacionalidad siria durante 120 años
sin embargo mas persona si eso por negar
para probar suerte es margen de éxtasis
relieves de selvi ernest dessena dei
migrantes caminan por la frontera
entrée bielorrusia y lituania a dirección a
Polonia y en el videoteatro publicado en
Sábado para la policía polaca migrantes
país un poco la frontera entrada de la
rusia polonia acompañado spohr
guardia de y lorusso mis sardinas lo
enviado bruto algunos consideran plantas allí
violencia sobre frida en sus espías el origen
la viga es maría si vale ana'a a fa
aquellos
para entregar a homs que están pensando
ven que un arma porque no tenemos futuro
claro que nina eni de lalut 9 st aunque
tenemos el b y c el ex de
conflicto geopolítico que sobre ellos
alta christie es la organización s si
también se refiere a sobre todo emergencias
humanitario a la situacion la frontera
desistirá y ahora querido por mil personas
escrito otra bola siempre lo
El aspecto europeo se da a los rusos un tra
Paz a un jefe que refrigere o no
drenar lo que se necesita en kansas lo que
esta crisis migratoria es staio up
insidioso d'este años la unión europea
acusa al presidente de Bielorrusia
aleksandr lukashenko de alimentarlo en
represalia por la atención a esto
sudario el viento se mueve brutalmente
represión de tu oponente